( intro music )
( applause )
So my name is Vicki Jensen,
I'm a virologist.
A lot of the work that I've done
over the past 15 years or so
has been on Ebola virus.
And I'd like to tell you
a little bit about
what it's like working
in that environment.
So, usually the first question
that I get asked
when I tell people
I work on Ebola is
"Why the heck would you
ever want to do that?"
And for me it actually started
back in college
when I was a freshman
taking an intro to micro course,
I read a book that
probably a lot of folks
in the room have read,
"The Hot Zone"
by Richard Preston.
And I think if you've
read the book,
you can understand how you would
easily become infatuated
with virology
and especially with Ebola virus.
For me though it
actually started a little
bit before that.
I was always interested
in viruses.
As a small child,
actually not that small,
probably 13 years old.
I remember learning about HIV.
And I remember being in class
with a friend of mine and
learning about this
and the two of us came up
with this great idea.
We were going to cure HIV.
We were going to have patients
sit in a chair,
hook them up,
take all their blood out,
boil it up, send it out,
get new blood back in and
we were going to cure HIV.
And that was my first,
I guess,
risk and failure in science.
And being a little bit naive
at the time.
But really virology is a
big puzzle, okay?
And these viruses,
Ebola in particular,
very, very simple.
Only has seven genes.
Lot of bang for its genomic buck
when you think of
all the havoc that it can wreak.
It's also extremely beautiful.
If you look at the
electron micrograph up there,
those are actually monkey cells
that are infected with
the virus.
And the string like particles
that you see
that completely cover the cell,
that's Ebola virus.
That's budding off of the cell
after it's been infected
for only about 48 hours.
The other virus shown here in
yellow and this is colorized,
of course,
is Lassa Fever virus.
So, most people have heard
about Ebola.
But there are lot of
different viruses
that cause a syndrome known as
Viral Hemorrhagic Fever.
And there's a lot of viruses
that are endemic to
certain regions,
like Lassa Fever
which is endemic
in West Africa.
Then there are viruses like
Ebola which
pop up from time to time.
Of course, we all know now
there's an ongoing outbreak
of Ebola in West Africa.
I think the current counts are
up over 17,000 cases,
over 6,000 deaths.
But as you can see
these viruses occur
pretty much all over the world.
And we even have some
in the United States.
Hantavirus Pulmonary Syndrome,
which a lot of people are
familiar with in the Midwest.
And with air travel the
way it is,
you can appreciate
how it would be really easy
to spread viruses
throughout the...
throughout the
entire world really.
And so,
that's how I got interested.
And so when we think
about viruses
we think of it in terms of
bio-safety risk.
And so if you look
at the very bottom
we start with
bio-safety level one.
And these are viruses, bacteria,
things that really don't cause
disease in healthy individuals.
As you go up a level,
bio-safety level two,
these might be your
hospital labs,
university labs,
things where you're dealing
with maybe E. Coli,
can cause human disease
but really nothing
too serious typically.
If you go up another level,
bio-safety level three,
that's when things start getting
a little more serious.
These are viruses and
bacteria where
you have higher case
fatality rates.
You have more personal
protective equipment
that we wear as
laboratorians so,
you may wear a face mask.
Or what we call a PAPR,
as you see here.
But typically at least for the
viruses in that category
there are some treatments,
there may be vaccines.
However when you go to the
pinnacle of this pyramid,
bio-safety level four,
you have the
highest case fatality rates,
they're all viruses,
there are no vaccines
and there are no therapies.
And there are very few labs
in the world
that are capable of
working with those agents.
So what is it like to
work in the lab?
It's fun sometimes.
It's cumbersome all the time.
And everything takes about
two-to-three times longer
than you would think.
So we work in
positive pressure suits.
The one up there is a white one.
And basically
if you look at the yellow hose,
that's an air hose.
We hook that up,
air gets pumped into our suit.
And that's one way
that we protect ourselves.
So, if we accidentally
get a hole in a glove,
a hole in a suit,
the air is always pushing things
out and away from us.
The lab itself,
is interesting because it is
almost like playing Tarzan.
If you want to get from
one area of the lab
to the other, it's not as simple
as just walking.
You're tethered to these
air hoses.
So, if you have things to carry,
you're having to
constantly stop and move.
The lab itself
is more than just a space
we work in.
So a lot of people
don't appreciate this,
but there's a ton of stuff,
mechanical space above us
where we have
HEPA-filtered air that goes in,
lots of back up breathing air,
all sorts of stuff like that.
Below we have decontamination
for all the fluids,
all the waste that goes out.
So everything that
leaves the lab
is dead.
So what is it like
working in there?
It's not like the movies.
Vaccines and treatments,
they're not developed in days,
weeks, months, years.
We fail a lot.
And by that I mean
for every therapy
that we've discovered
we've tested hundreds,
thousands more that have failed.
Now with the recent
Ebola outbreak,
we have had a lot more progress.
Things are moving
more rapidly, which
some would argue,
I would argue is unfortunate
it takes something like that
to get things moving so quickly.
So, one of the things
we do a lot is mitigate risk.
So, even though we have
these suits that we work in
that's not our primary means of
containing the virus.
So we actually do all
of our work
in bio-safety cabinets.
So, if we have a spill,
it's contained there.
The suit is really
meant to be as a backup.
And so, when we think about
failure in science
I like to think
it's really how you perceive it.
My mentor told me when I was
getting into this field,
"if you're successful
ten percent of the time,
you're doing really awesome."
And so I think of it
if I have an experiment
that doesn't work,
it's an opportunity,
it's an experience
we've learned something.
And so, one of my
favorite quotes
that I always think of
when I think of failure and
risk is from Thomas Edison.
And this is when
he was creating the light bulb.
And he said
he hadn't failed 10,000 times.
He hadn't failed even once.
He actually succeeded in proving
those 10,000 ways
would not work.
And that when he eliminated
all of those ways,
then he would find the way
that would work.
And so,
I leave you with that thought.
Thanks.
( applause )
( outro music )